I'm hoping it'll be done in March the
Senate is working all right send the
dogs been doing a very good job but he
does have the problem of the 40 vote
barrier it's unfortunate that the
Constitution has been amended de facto
to say that you need 60 senators pass
something I don't think that's the
spirit of but you already ruled but
that's where we are
he's working hard on it and we've been
in touch I expect him to be able to get
a bill done by March we have the
February break coming up and I I do
think the bills will be close enough
there's a great similarity we've been
working together work with the
administration so that it won't take us
more than a week or so to reconcile the
two so I am very hopeful the president
both showing that before we break for
spring
it's gonna be a significant improvement
in every area there will be much tighter
regulation of derivatives which cost a
great deal of a problem most importantly
there will be an entity probably a
Council of the existing federal
regulators who will be charged with
something that no one was charged with
before looking out for systemic risk
looking out for that pattern of activity
or individual entity that could cause
such problems that the whole system
would fall and if we deal with that two
ways in our bill and I think that bill
will be very close first of all we give
the regulator's the power to say stop it
stop issuing credit default swaps
greatly increase your capital loans we
want to stop people well before they get
to the cliff if for some reason that
doesn't work and some institution does
become so indebted that its failure to
pay its debts would cause systemic
problems that institution is abolished
there will be no more too big to fail if
you get the trouble you will fail as
I've said we will enact death panels in
the Congress this Congress but there'll
be four financial institutions that
ought to be put to death there may be
the need for the federal government to
pay some of the debts and we give them
the power to pick and choose the problem
we had 2008 was that as interpreted by
the bush administration secretary
Paulson Fed Chairman Bernanke bush
appointees they believed that if an
institution found an old a lot of money
they in ways it would cause bumps they
had to pay everybody or nobody
they had no no option and we say no the
assumption should be paid over t and if
you have to pay to avoid terrible
damages you can do that selectively and
most importantly the money won't come
from the federal taxpayer it will come
from fees raised by the financial
institutions themselves AIG is the most
egregious example of a federal
intervention where we probably won't get
the money back there was a Bush
administration decision without any
congressional input
Chairman Bernanke and secretary Paulson
came to us in September of 2008 and said
we have decided to use powers that the
Federal Reserve has to use money they
control to bail out the people who I
owed money to we could kill that in the
future the Federal Reserve if our bills
pass will not have the power
and make payments to a particular
company an addiction and this is very
important we have created a consumer
protection agency right now consumer
protection is done almost as an
afterthought frankly by the bank
regulators the Federal Reserve is the
largest holder of consumer statutory
powers consumer regulatory powers they
don't focus on that alan greenspan a
particular didn't believe in it that's a
philosophy he thought the market would
take care of everything to his credit
he's admitted that was wrong we create a
separate Consumer Financial Protection
Agency the banks are fighting that
harder that's one of the major things
that Senator Dodd is trying to save over
there in the Senate
I should have we also have a very
important provision involving what's
called securitization thirty years ago
if you borrowed money
the person who lent you the money was
the person you were going to pay back
and if I'm gonna lend you money and
you're gonna pay me back I'm gonna be
careful about the person I lend to then
came securitization whereby people lend
money and then sell the right to be paid
back and not surprisingly they're not as
careful we are requiring the regulator's
to say that if you do that and you sell
the loan you have to retain 5% of it and
you get the first 5% of loss and if it's
a risky loan you got to keep 10% of it
that may not seem huge but if you look
at the percentage of the profit that
represents it's significant we also say
if you're making a very safe
conventional loan a 30-year fixed
interest rate mortgage with a
significant down payment in that case
the regulator's could allow you if they
think it's very safe to hold none of it
but we think that will be very helpful
and finally I should say we give the
Reagan is the power to break up
institutions Congress repealed I'm going
to know the glass-steagall Act ten years
ago
it allowed banks to become conglomerates
I don't think you can now retroactively
reorder them all to be broken up that
would cause more chaos at a weak time in
the economy but we are saying to the
regulators if you see a particular
institution that's getting into trouble
or it's too overextended
you can order them to sell this piece or
sell that piece and you can order them
to reduce in size that's the essential
package oh one last point we are
specifically banning the kind of
subprime mortgages they respond
Paul Morgan is mortgages given to people
who shouldn't have gotten them who
couldn't afford them who had interest
rate triggers I'm going to go way up we
simply make those here we go
well the answer is that you didn't have
to capture people who were willing under
the Bush administration in particular
but to some extent under the Clinton
administration the dominant philosophy
was the market knows best and in 1994
Congress passed a bill to give the
Federal Reserve the power to regulate
subprime mortgages no matter who gave
them not just from banks alan greenspan
explicitly refused to use that tower he
said what the market knows better than I
he now admits that that was the cause of
an era because the single biggest
problem you had with all those mortgages
that were made that couldn't be paid
that were then sent out and sold out and
closed they were the base of that chain
reaction so the answer is and and the
Clinton administration was was better
than the Bush administration when the
Bush administration came in they
appointed people who didn't believe in
regulation so I was not did the bank's
captured them it's that they volunteered
to become parts of the of that operation
well I find joseph stiglitz who was the
chairman of the Council of Economic
Advisers under President Clinton and we
then fired from the World Bank because
he was being critical of their policies
that were that were that were anti
working people I have found him to be
extremely thoughtful Paul Volcker's the
former chairman the Federal Reserve who
preceded Alan Greenspan is an example of
someone who understands the financial
community but also knows precisely
because he does that you need regulation
and Paul Volcker has been someone we
have paid attention to Elizabeth Warren
has been a major guide in the consumer
area she's a professor at Harvard Law
School who began to look into the
consumer area and one of things I'm
proudest of is that when we passed the
bill in the committee I chair to create
a Consumer Financial Protection Agency
not everything we wanted but but more
than 90% of it Elizabeth Warren was very
very congratulatory and she said and I
love this quote they told me he came up
with the idea of the consumer agency
they told me not even to try to get such
an agency because in Washington the
banks always win well they didn't win
today so those are three people who have
had an impact Joe Stiglitz on the
overall economic importance Paul Volcker
on the regulatory area and always was
one of the consumer protection
but make it a meal and we do that in the
bill that we pass and I think the Senate
will pick you right in 2004 the
republican-controlled Congress in 2004
some of us on the Democratic side try to
pass further legislation we given the
federal reserve the right to regulate
subprime mortgages now we want to go
beyond that just out or some of them the
Republicans in control said no we don't
we don't believe in that we don't we
know that regulation they wouldn't do
any of what was go forth on what we do
in our bill is first of all to say that
no federal funds can go to keep the
institution in business too big to fail
meant that the institution would be kept
going we make that illegal no federal
money can go for that there might be
money used to pay off some of the debts
if the failure to pay any of the debts
would cause a systemic crisis but that
won't be taxpayer dollars we also in our
bill did a couple of other important
things one over the objection of many of
the financial industry we said that well
first I should say under the bill
nothing can be done including paying off
some of those debts to purvey to prevent
a crisis until all the shareholder money
is wiped out until all the board of
directors and executives are fired the
institution is over that's statutory and
it's illegal to do anything other than
that before that we have a systemic risk
regulator that steps in and would have
said to an AIG you are way over extended
you must stop selling credit default
swaps you must greatly increase the
capital you have to hold against losses
in addition we say with regard to the
too-big-to-fail operation that you tell
them in advance we're gonna break you up
we don't want you getting into that sort
of position where you owe more money
than you could conceivably pay but the
fundamental point we'll make is this if
it does not work and an institution does
get someone dead if that is tucán over
and one last point over the objection of
many in the financial community and not
requested by the Obama administration we
added an amendment hotly-contested that
said even if you're a secured creditor
of one of those institutions we don't
have to pay everything we may give you a
10% haircut and
we want to make people very nervous I'll
tell you one thing I was very proud of
the securities industry and financial
marketing association which represents
them securities people they objected to
our bill in how we deal with the
institution that's gonna be put out of
business they said our bill was was not
creditor friendly
they said the Republican approach was
better for creditors that goes
particularly the question of too big to
fail and of moral hazard in other words
our bill says to the creditors hey you
better check on the security of that
institution because of that institution
gets overextended do not count on us to
come to your rescue certainly not if you
an unsecured creditor and even if you're
a secured creditor we may only pay 10%
by 90 percent
no I change those Jews when the Bush
administration changed what Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac were doing I did believe
that Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac should
be used to build affordable rental
housing when I said affordable housing
there it's the terms of UGS I was talk
about rental housing I had been critical
of the push for Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac to buy up subprime mortgages and in
2003 I did not see a crisis because I
will tell you I didn't see a crisis with
Lehman Brothers or AIG I mean we did not
have I did not perceive the crisis as
much as it was I think it was encouraged
and brought about by subprime lending
and here's the sequence the year after I
said that 2004 the book administration
ordered Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
significantly to increase the number of
mortgages they bought issued to
low-income people I criticized that at
the time in 2004 there's another quote
that doesn't get mentioned as much in
Bloomberg saying this is bad for the
borrowers and it's bad for Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac we couldn't overrule
that the Bush administration put in a
significant increase in the number of
one-week of mortgages in fact one of the
Republican members of the committee put
an amendment in on the history which
specifically mentioned that 2004
decisions by the Bush administration the
republican-controlled Congress they
didn't let us stop it
once that happened I did agree that we
need to regulate Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac I should note by the way that during
the period 2003 I was in the minority I
was a Democrat in a congress controlled
by Tom DeLay so no I didn't really have
the power to decide that the Republicans
during that twelve years of control did
nothing to to deal with it
in 2005 though I will say this in 2003 I
didn't see crisis in 2004 I was critical
of them pushing into more subprime loans
we did two things first Democrats try to
restrict subprime loans the Republicans
wouldn't entertain the bill and
Greenspan wouldn't use his authority to
do it
secondly I joined the Republican
chairman of the committee then Mike
Oxley in trying to regulate Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac now I voted in committee
for a bill in 2005 to regulate Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac I was in the
minority remember this is a Republican
Congress the bill passed the
he went to the floor at that point the
Republican leadership ordered actually
to put in an amendment that cut out
affordable rental housing I voted
against the bill because of that but I
was still for the penny made for any Mac
regulation but here's the point this is
a Republican Congress the Republican
Congress in 2005 with my support passes
out of committee a bill to regulate
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in the house
it goes to the Senate and the bush
administration tells the Senate
Republicans who controlled the Senate
that they don't like what the House
Republicans did so the bill then dies
because of a fight between the House
Republicans in the Senate Republicans I
joined Oxley in writing to the Senate
Republicans and saying please pass a
regulatory bill and so again without the
public in control of Congress Mike Oxley
the chairman of the committee the man
who gave his name to sarbanes-oxley said
the reason they didn't get Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac relation that year was that
the Bush administration bought it and he
said that he got a one-finger salute
from George Bush this was quoted in the
Financial Times and that's what Pontic
the secretary the Treasury at the time
Jon Snow agreed with actually that it
was a good bill but the more
conservative Republicans I think they
were opposed to any kind of housing help
so it died in 2007 the Democrats became
the majority we won the election 2006 I
became the chairman of the committee in
2007 within a few months of my becoming
chairman the committee that I chaired
passed a tough Fannie Mae Freddie Mac
regulatory bill frankly tougher than the
one that actually had been able to get
through Hank Paulson the Secretary of
Treasury he supported it unfortunate was
held up by the Republican and Democratic
fighting in the Senate someone to
summarize 2003 I said I didn't see a
problem in 2004 when Bush ordered them
to do more about subprime mortgages and
wouldn't regulate subprime mortgages I
said yeah there is a problem 2005 I
joined my Cox Lee and trying to pass a
bill to regulate Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac it was defeated by introvert public
and feuding Republican House Republican
Senate Republican president in 2007 when
I for the first time was the chairman
and we were in the majority
we passed the good bill unfortunately it
was delayed in the Senate until 2008
about that time too many subprime
mortgages had been born it was too late
2004 the Bush administration
significantly increased those housing
goals and particularly ordered Freddie
and Fannie to start buying up a lot of
low-income individual mortgages and I
opposed it at the time
I do think going forward we have to
separate out the function of providing
liquidity for the mortgage market in
general and some form of subsidy they
should not be in the same entity it was
a mistake to have them in the same
shareholder own corporation and I
believe going forward you're gonna see a
total rewriting of housing finance some
of this can go one of these that
happened under the Bush administration
with the FHA was allowed to deteriorate
we're building that back up again with
safeguards so I think the answer is you
separate out the function of providing
liquidity in general for the mortgage
market and doing some subsidy and in my
judgment the subsidy again as I said
before should be focused on affordable
rental housing not in pushing low-income
people in the only homes they can't
afford
absolutely I think that the arguments
that are being made against this are to
use a technical economic term entirely
bogus they didn't just get tarp money
they say we repaid the tarp money well
they did but you know getting alone at a
time when no one else will give it to
you is a benefit even if you later repay
it but there were many other programs by
the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation and the Federal Reserve and
the Secretary of Treasury to help the
financial institutions it was very
frustrating for many Americans because
it was these financial institutions
irresponsibility that had brought about
the financial crisis and then to get out
of this terrible crisis to avoid a again
bush and bushes top economic appointees
Bernanke and Paulson came to us in
September of 2008 and said if you don't
act there'll be a total meltdown
there'll be the worst depression ever by
the way even if you didn't think that
was gonna be the case and I think it
probably was when the Secretary of
Treasury and the Federal Reserve say if
you don't do this there'll be a meltdown
there's gonna be a meltdown it's a
little bit self-fulfilling and anyway we
responded and you had to save the
economy we had to do something to help
the banks that was infuriating the
people but there was no other way around
it given the centrality of credit in our
economy so yeah I think it's entirely
reasonable now as a matter of fact that
idea that the banks have to pay for it
was in the original bill we passed now
that the Bush administration's request
but the Democratic Congress is
initiative to require that the financial
institutions repay this and it doesn't
just have to be what what they got out
of the tarp they got aid in a lot of
other ways they tell us oh but if you
make us pay this tax we won't have any
money to lend first of all they're doing
a lousy job of lending now and we'll be
having a hearing couple weeks after this
interview to force them to do more if we
can but secondly the bonuses they're
giving each other far outweigh every
year the taxes so if paying this nine or
ten billion dollars a year in taxes it's
gonna be a problem then what about the
hundred billion dollars in bonuses so
that's why I say it's entirely bogus
oh I didn't I don't have to use
hindsight I was against it at the time
you have to separate it out by
affordable housing we have generally met
rental housing one of the great
conservative mistakes was to kill rental
housing programs and say the way to help
low-income people with housing is to
help them buy homes frankly in many
parts of the country how do you so
expensive following the people to buy
homes I have been a critic I'm very
proud of a man named Larry Lindsey who
was a high economic appointee of
President Reagan and both bushes cited
me is one of the few political figures
who specifically was critical of pushing
lower income people in a homeownership
yeah I think that was a terrible idea
and I said so at the time I wanted to do
more affordable rental housing I had an
argument with the Secretary of HUD mr.
Jackson pushing Secretary of HUD and he
said he wanted to cut off section 8 for
people after 5 years that's the rental
assistance I said well mr. secretary
where will they live he said we'll help
them become homeowners so yeah I think
it was a terrible mistake and I said so
at the time to push low-income people
into homeownership some can do it but
rental housing was better and it was
unfortunately ideologically opposed
I don't know I I overreacted the day of
the Matthews election and said you know
maybe we have to stop this because some
of my Democratic colleagues were talking
about doing some things that I thought
were not procedurally appropriate that
was an overreaction on my part because I
die I want to make sure we didn't do
anything
some people talk about well should we
not seek this guy for why our pass the
bill before that it wasn't serious but I
yeah I really thought we needed to nail
that down now I don't know I do want to
try to go forward this is very important
that 60 vote problem in the Senate is
there one question is what gets senator
Olympia Snowe who voted for a version of
the bill is she gonna continue insist on
nothing I want to do some things yeah I
certainly believe if we can pass a
package of things that make the current
situation better and help people with
pre-existing conditions that don't allow
a lifetime cap sure I think you always
want to try and make things better but
exactly how best to do that is still
being discussed now
well one we have passed a major
legislation we passed the Children's
Health expansion we passed a good bill
to reverse any discrimination we passed
a good economic recovery bill which has
held unemployment down but I wonder
would have been over Republican
objections the other answer though was
this when the republics were passing
legislation we were in a good economy
unfortunately the economy was
deteriorating I think it's a consequence
of their refusal to regulate the
financial industry and President Obama
inherited one of the worst recessions in
history the worst since the Great
Depression and is much harder to do
things in a very depressed economy with
revenues tied up and people hurting than
it was in a good economy so by the
policies that led to this terrible
recession that Obama inherited things
became more difficult